B Bonsoir, Stéphanie Chouinard,
MiMichel David, Jonathan Trudea.
LoLoi 21 vers la Cour suprême?
LoLoi sur la laïcité de l'État,e
gogouvernement fédéral va y
paparticiper, Monsieur Trudeau
l'l'avait pas mal indiqué.
RéRéaction à Québec :
JUJUSTIN TRUDEAU,
prpremier ministre du Canada
- - Nous avons des préoccupatios
papar rapport aux propositions
ququ'on fait le... au projet de
loloi du gouvernement provincia.
EtEt en tant que gouvernement
féfédéral, je pense que tout le
momonde comprend que nous devons
êêtre là pour protéger les drois
fofondamentaux de tous
leles Canadiens, où qu'ils soiet
dadans notre pays.
DADAVID LAMETTI, ministre fédérl
dede la Justice, procureur génél
- - Une fois que la cour d'appea
trtranchée, on va devant la cour
susuprême pour donner nos opinis
llà-dessus parce que ça devient,
papar définition, un enjeu
nanational, une fois que ça arre
àà la cour suprême du Canada.
DoDonc, nous y serons.
FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
prpremier ministre du Québec
- - Le ministre Lametti, donc un
miministre de Justin Trudeau, qi
avavant même d'avoir la décision
dede la Cour d'appel, dit
ququ'il va aller en Cour suprême
popour contester la loi 21,
lala loi qui interdit les signes
reliligieux pour les personnes
ququi sont en autorité, c'est
unun manque de respect flagrant
dede Justin Trudeau envers les
QuQuébécois puisqu'on sait qu'iy
a a une majorité de Québécois qi
sosont d'accord avec la loi 21.
EtEt donc, Justin Trudeau vient
didire : Bien moi, je vais aller
meme mêler de ,ça puis je vais
alaller contre la volonté
d'd'une majorité de Québec.
C'C'est un manque de respect
cocomplet de sa part.
- - Alors Stéphanie Chouinard je
cocommence avec vous, est-ce que
cece n'était pas déjà planifié e
lele gouvernement fédéral allait
sese mêler?
- - Oui, on le savait déjà. À
mamaintes reprises notamment aux
dedernières élections fédérales,
lala question avait été posée :
esest-ce qu'un gouvernement
féfédéral allait intervenir sura
loloi 21? Et à toutes les
rereprises, Monsieur Trudeau a t
onon refusait de fermer la port.
EnEn redoutait fortement ce quie
prpréparait en cour suprême, que
lele gouvernement fédéral allait
dedemander à intervenir.
- - M. Legault est fâché?
- - Ce qui me surprend de la pat
dede Monsieur Trudeau, c'est dee
fafaire maintenant. Je ne
cocomprends pas pourquoi la cour
d'd'appel a pas encore rendu son
jujugement et qu'il est rendu en
cocour suprême. Il fait une crie
d'd'indignation aussi imprévisie
quque la décision de Monsieur
TrTrudeau d'aller en cour suprê.
IlIl semble que ça fait son
afaffaire à la veille des
élélections. À la veille des
élélections les jeux sont
prpratiquement faits au Québec.
L'L'adversaire pour M. Trudeau
sesera sûrement M. Legault. Il a
prpréparer son mandat et je
m'm'attends à ce qu'il soit fére
àà l'endroit du gouvernement
féfédéral. Ça va être avantageux
popour lui.
- - Il va devoir demander tous s
popouvoirs... comment vous avez
dédéconné les déclarations de la
journée?
- - Essentiellement que la
papandémie est vraiment dernière
nonous, c'est comme ça que je le
dédécode. Je partage vivement ce
sesentiment de nausées profondes
majorité de la population
ququébécoise de revoir encore ue
fofois ces mêmes chicanes la. Oa
fafait une campagne là-dessus sr
cecette espèce de jeudi fédéral.
IlIl vient de le confirmer.
CoComme Michel a dit...
dadans des situations comme ça
FrFrançois Legault bien vraiment
pepersonnaliser les enjeux. Jusn
TrTrudeau vient le personnaliseà
JuJustin Trudeau. Je pense que a
lelecture de François Legault
VaValbonne à l'effet que ça va
êêtre payant pour lui de faire
dedes reproches à ce niveau-là u
gogouvernement fédéral parce que
j'j'ai toujours pensé que l'appi
mamassif de la loi 21 s'expliqut
dede deux façons bien simples.
PrPremièrement il y a une partie
dedes citoyens qui ont une soif
prprofonde de la laïcité, une
auautre partie qui veut juste
papasser à autre chose qui est
tatannée d'entendre parler de ce
dédébat la. Or on a encore un pu
l'l'impression qu'on est passé à
auautre chose, ça ne revient.
- - Ça va être long parce qu'on
esest pas encore rendu à la cour
susuprême. On écoute Monsieur
LaLametti qu'il a aussi, il ditn
prprenant cet exemple la  que le
gogouvernement du Québec appliqe
lala clause dérogatoire comme au
bobouclier, on aime pas ça.
DADAVID LAMETTI, ministre fédérl
dede la Justice, Canada
- - Nous avons des préoccupatios
susur l'utilisation préemptive
dede la clause dérogatoire. Je e
sosouviens des débats, à l'époq,
c'c'était supposé d'être
lele dernier mot dans un dialoge
enentre les tribunaux et
leles législatures, et pas
lele premier mot. Et quand c'est
ememployé, surtout dans une façn
omomnibus, quand c'est employé
cocomme le premier mot, sa coupe
lele débat politique. Et comme
lele cours supérieur l'annotait,
çaça coupe aussi la révision
jujuridique. Et ce n'est pas, ds
unune démocratie... Ce n'est pas
sosouhaitable.
- - Et ça, ça pourrait être
cocontesté et soulevé. Stéphanie
ChChouinard, utilisation de la
clclause dérogatoire comme
paparapluie avant... avant ils
aiaiment pas ça?
- - Oui, il y a sept ans je la,
memets avec la loi 96 il y a dex
enenjeux qui seront peut-être ps
cocouverts par la clause
dédérogatoire parce qu'il ne fat
papas oublier qu'il y a certains
ararticles de la charte canadiee
dedes droits et libertés qui ne
sosont pas assujetties à la clae
dédérogatoire. Ça date de la
chcharte constitutionnelle de
191967. Il y a un vaste champ
d'd'application de la loi 96
nonotamment dans le domaine de
l'l'accessibilité à la justice u
lala clause dérogatoire ne
s's'applique même pas. Ça sera
ququand même assez intéressant e
vovoir à quoi vont ressembler cs
dédécisions.
- - Sur la loi 96, il dit par
aiailleurs qu'on va être vigila,
llà aussi quand même on fait des
papas, on avance, c'est comme si
dudu côté fédéral à part elle
avavait été libérée?
- - Ah oui je m'attends à ce que
lele gouvernement fédéral
inintervienne éventuellement das
lele processus judiciaire à une
ététape ou un autre. Je pense qe
çaça va éventuellement se rendre
lala. Utilisation de la clause
dédérogatoire, c'est moins odiex
dede l'introduire dans l'entréee
jejeu que d'attendre que la cour
ininvalide loi et ensuite allerà
l'l'encontre d'un jugement de la
cocour. Politiquement, c'est
bebeaucoup plus délicat de le
fafaire. Alors, via sa. Autre pt
jeje pense que Monsieur Legaultn
inintroduisant des je voulais
fafaire une affirmation de
prprincipe pour protéger non
seseulement la loi, mais dire qe
cece sont les législatures et
paparlementaires qui ont d'entré
jejeu de le droit de définir les
rrègles. Ce n'est pas à la cour
dede venirir nous le dire. C'esn
vivieux débat, c'est là que la
chcharte a été introduite dans a
coconstitution mais ce n'est pas
popolitiquement réglé. C'est
enencore contesté qui est le
papatron en définitive? En avoir
enencore une autre manifestatio.
- - Jonathan, c'est un débat
enencore une fois qui aura lieu
avavec les libéraux et les
cacaquiste, les libéraux disent
ququ'ils sont contre l'utilisatn
dede cette clause en général, ms
n'n'ont-ils dit clairement?
- - En même temps, je me demande
dede quel droit le ministre
LaLametti questionne les occasis
çaça c'est pertinent d'utiliseru
nonon la clause dérogatoire s'is
veveulent contester devant les
trtribunaux, libre à eux de le
fafaire. La position, on va
coconfirmer que la position sure
prprojet de loi 96 serait analoe
àà la loi 21. Ce ne seront pas
eueux qui vont initier les
dédémarches mais se feront
enentendre le cas d'éventuelle
dédémarche. Le plein entier du
gogouvernement fédéral, la seule
chchose... on le voit dans la
réréaction de député du Parti
lilibéral, le candidat à la coue
àà la chefferie du parti
coconservateur... je suis loin e
pepenser que son projet de loi t
paparfait, je pense qu'il aurait
pupu être bonifié. Je pense qu'l
sesera bonifié à travers le tem.
MaMais de là à aller affirmer
ququ'on enlève des droits aux
AnAnglais et que les anglophones
nene pourront plus se faire
sosoigner, on n'y va avec des
dedemies vérités et ça accentuee
clclivage avec le reste du Québ.
- - Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
lala couverture, Stéphanie, sur
leles soins de santé parce qu'is
onont essayé d'être clair, qu'e-
cece que vous pensez de ce qu'on
didit de cette loi ailleurs?
- - C'est difficile. Lorsque l'n
rerentre dans les débats
lilinguistiques autant l'extérir
dudu Québec au Québec, on a
sosouvent à faire des positions
trtrop tranchées qui manquent de
nunuance. On voit qu'il y a des
acacteurs qui tentent de profitr
dede ce type de débat la. Malgré
lele fait que le gouvernement
tetente justement de mettre les
chchoses au clair, on voit qu'il
dedemeure des craintes. Sacrées
glglaçons tenu p par une partiee
lala population québécoise. Par
rarapport à certains débats qui
onont déjà eu lieu, le projet de
loloi 96 n'a quand même pas
sususcité des patients au Canada
ananglais comme à l'adoption dea
loloi 101 dans les années 70. On
esest très loin du type de
rhrhétorique assez inflammatoire
ququ'on retrouvait dans ses méda
AnAnglo canadien. Ça demeure le
phphénomène qu'on parle, mais
c'c'est pas comment 77.
- - La réaction de la communauté
ananglophone a été assez
vivirulente, mais au sein de la
cocommunauté francophone ce n'et
papas un débat qui a passionné
bebeaucoup. Si je reviens aux
crcraintes exprimées par les
ananglophones, ce n'est pas
jujustifié. Il y a une loi sur
l'l'accès aux services en angla,
leles services en santé en angls
ququi n'est pas songé par le
prprojet de loi 96. Et de façon
gégénérale il y a une affirmatin
ququi dise que les services
dedevront être rendus en franças
avavec l'exception de la santé t
lala sécurité, la justice
nanationale. Je ne vois pas du
totout sur quelle base on se bae
ouou se fonde pour faire des
acaccusations pareilles. Je liss
dadans une chronique dans le
dedevoir ce matin on parlait de
didiffamation...
- - j'ajouterai si je peux me
pepermettre que le fédéral
popourrait aussi s'occuper de ss
prpropres plates-bandes. Comment
çaça avance le projet de la
miministre Taylor?
C'C'est un projet de loi qui n't
papas encore adoptée on parle ts
pepeu qui vise entre autres des
ororganismes fédérales. Quand on
reregarde la situation et quandn
pepense à Air Canada, le conseil
d'd'administration du CN, je pee
quque le fédéral a des chats à
fofouetter de son côté pour
prprotéger les minorités
lilinguistiques avant de faire a
leleçon au Québec.
- - Un petit mot sur l'importane
dudu débat conservateur sur le
prprojet fédéral?
- - Justement on entendait la
miministre Taylor lancer les
coconsultations sur les langues
ofofficielles un plan d'action i
dedevrait entrer en oeuvre en 23
l'l'année prochaine. On a
l'l'impression que le gouvernemt
féfédéral mais la charrue devant
leles boeufs. C'est maintenant n
dedeuxième lecture mais ça ne se
rerendra certainement pas en éte
dede comité d'ici les vacances
d'd'été. On imagine très mal que
cece projet de loi sera adopté
d'd'ici 2022 si la tendance se
mamaintient alors qu'on pense dà
àà une nouvelle politique
ququinquennale. On est encore ds
lala loi de 1988. Du côté du
gogouvernement fédéral, on a aui
efeffectivement les bras pleins.
- - Débat, dernier débat en
frfrançais ce soir des candidats
coconservateurs. D'abord, j'ai
prpris pour que le format, le
momodèle soit pas le même que le
dedernier en anglais, c'était
épépouvantable, mais qu'on laise
dédébattre les gens. Vous vous
atattendez à quoi est-ce que c't
imimportant? Un tour de table.e.
- - Ça m'a été confirmé que le
foformat est différent. On parle
dede neuf thèmes. Par la suite e
sesera des échanges ouvertes, ds
écéchanges d'une durée de quatre
miminutes. Il ne devrait pas y
avavoir des questions sur la
lelecture de chevet préféré de
chchacun des candidats. Entre
dédétails, on m'a confirmé qu'on
sosonge peut-être parti
coconservateur organiser un aute
dédébat parce qu'il y a une plae
dede trois mois entre débat sigé
lele 10 septembre. Donc semble--
ilil que c'est dans l'air. Quand
mmême un débat intéressant parce
quque ça va être suivi au Québec
dadans les communautés
frfrancophones. J'ai de voir
cocomment Jean Charest v va réur
àà s'en sortir par rapport à
PiPierre Poilièvre qui va être
enencore un foie très agressif.e
meme demande si on assiste pas e
peperte de momentum de Pierre
PoPoilièvre...
- -  il en fait trop...
MiMichel?
- - On espère que le format, les
rrèglements les plus
inintéressants. Ça va être un
dédébat assez pénible dans la
memesure où il y a quatre des
cacandidats qui ne parlent pas
frfrançais. Ça sera entre Monsir
ChCharvet et Monsieur Poilièvre.
C'C'est important parce que
MoMonsieur Charest doit absolumt
fafaire le plein de votre Québec
s's'il veut avoir une chance de
cocompenser pour la langue de
MoMonsieur Poilièvre ailleurs.
- - Stéphanie?
- - On espère que ce sera pas ue
trtrès longue histoire d'empoige
enentre Monsieur Poilièvre et
MoMonsieur Charest parce que ce
seseront les deux qui vont domir
pupuisqu